this morning Warner Brothers an ABC if
you guys missed it have announced that
bachelor in paradise
production will resume that they've
completed their investigation that no
evidence of wrongdoing was found
involved in the incident that of course
involves current elympios into Mario
Jackson and that they're gonna be
filming paradise again how did you guys
feel when you heard this news um I was
really surprised I still really know
what's going on be interesting to kind
of see moving forward yeah how they
proceed
Robbie you were supposed to be in
paradise you went to paradise how did
you feel hearing the news that the show
will be producing and resuming again it
was surprising it's crazy I didn't think
there's a chance that would come back
you know I thought with everything that
went on the morality of it and the name
of it might have been tainted a little
bit but one er brothers released a
pretty Stern statement and all the
statements they release are Stern so I'm
excited to see what happens so when
you're saying the morality of it and
everything went on what were you feeling
like what's going to happen with the
show what was your prediction I wasn't
sure if they were going to bring
paradise back replace paradise with a
different more domestic type of show or
just have nothing I knew that they had
the airtime already purchased over the
summer for those time slots on Monday
Tuesday night I didn't know if they
would do reruns if they would fill it
with you know something else they tried
to shoot in inside the country and not
in Mexico kind of give it a different
name and start that or go back to
bachelor pad I don't know there's a lot
of things that are going through your
mind because you are very dark and they
keep you in the dark would you return to
paradise I have to see I don't know the
timeline you know I had scheduled some
things now that I was back in the states
some stuff with legal ethics amongst
other things do you guys think that
Corinne and Demario should return to
paradise
I personally don't think so I think
you'd better moving forward if they
don't if they don't go and they continue
to film probably first Thursday's too
but I've not gonna rule it out if they
bring them in for some final comments if
they do pick back up but I don't think
they should be it will be interesting to
see how things are handled when
production comes back if like the fact
that it was shut down is addressed it's
kind of like the idea in the room how
could she not yeah yeah so it's a
reality show it's real misty says Robby
I'm just really hoping you find
upset thank you Miss
[Music]